Joell is with us in Lancaster
Pennsylvania hi Joelle how are you yeah
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up Oh looking a quick question
I'm just starting the whole budget stuff
and I was not sure if I should based my
budget on my regular 80-hour period or
shot calculate my overtime with that
well what you do is you do a budget a
new one for each month and so if you
think this month you're going to have
overtime you use the overtime money in
the budget because the budgets supposed
to represent reality it's not you don't
do a budget for that's the template
where every month looks alike because
every month doesn't look alike and work
or expenses and so you say are in the
month of January
what's my income going to look like and
you give every one of those dollars a
name every one of those dollars an
assignment and then net when you come to
February you get ready to do it again
but you can project out a month what
your overtime is going to look like
can't you oh yeah that's right simply
try to get at least ten hours minimum
per pay period because you have it two
weeks yeah and if you weren't going to
do that in the month of February when
you get to the end of January you would
know that February might be a little
less right you'd know in advance and so
you do February's budget before February
gets here at the end of January you do
January's budget now you're late and so
that's how you do it because then you're
then your prediction of your income is
going to be very fairly accurate because
you're pretty much gonna know like you
said right now I'm working ten hours
extra now I hope you do that for four
weeks in the month of January then
that's going to be your income and
you'll be able to this is my pay pit
look at the pay times and how many times
you're gonna get paid if you're paid
weekly some once you get more checks
than other months and so you and you're
doing it by the month so jump on every
dollar it will help you put all of this
together Joelle it's a free app for your
iPhone or your Android or your desktop
and you can look at it at every dollar
calm and work it through that way check
that I think that will help you get
started if you have more question
if you get into that give me a yell back
and I'll help you walk through it hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]